chapter 280 of mikey academia is the
redemption that hiroshima has been
looking for
since before he even joined ua among
other interesting things this chapter
we also saw the return of shigaraki as
it's been quite a few chapters since he
last appeared in the manga
and let's just say things all around
generally look in favor of the heroes
but
i i wonder how long it's gonna stay that
way just before we get into it
as usual i need to remind you guys that
this is a review of the chapter leaks
and not the official chapter release
itself what that means is that whilst
the core
events are generally accurate stuff like
the dialogue and certain details
may turn out to be different when the
official chapter comes out on the shonen
jump app but without further ado
don't forget to sub as we are
tantalizingly close to a hundred
thousand we are nearly nearly nearly
there
and then i can shut up about it um but
yeah if you're not subscribed already
be sure to hit that button okay so the
chapter begins with the ua students
reacting to a massive blast of fire from
derby this flame attack actually
occurred during the last chapter
and it was so vicious that dabby's arm
became even more smoky than usual
even toga was concerned while some
students managed to avoid the blast
sarah states that others weren't so
lucky but that said
there are characters like hiroshima and
tatsutetsu who are just still pushing
forward despite being caught up in those
flames
we also see kaminari is in pretty bad
shape after he was hit by a bunch of
debris from mr compress
in the last chapter the scene then pans
to mina who's charging straight at
giganto makia
and she surrounded herself in her acid
man armor we first saw this move over 20
chapters ago
and back then she claimed it was her
version of red rio unbreakable
acid man makes her impervious to darby's
flames so she's able to get quite close
to makia
and she briefly hesitates in fear of
this colossal monster i mean
i would be afraid of him too in this
moment she then thinks back to what
mineta said about the possibility of
midnight being dead
which she probably is but maybe she'll
somehow come out of it
it's just a terrible situation all round
so mina is understandably a bit hesitant
to continue
meanwhile machia himself begins to
ramble on about his lord and savior
shigaraki
and the leaks say that he receives a
command from shigaraki
telling him to reach him by the shortest
distance possible
it's unclear if this is a memory like
machia remembering what shiguraki said
or if maybe shiguraki took some time out
of his current battle to
send makia a voice note that much is
unclear from the leagues
but either way the big guy is thinking
about it in this moment when he's
talking to himself
mina recognizes makia's voice and thinks
back to the time that she encountered
him
before she joined ua she then
acknowledges the fear that she felt back
then when she encountered him
but at the same time she's grown in
countless ways since that moment
and she imagines herself in her middle
school uniform as she throws the
anesthetic towards machia's mouth
this symbolizes not just overcoming her
fear right now in this moment
but also the fear that she had before
however as she does this
makia suddenly slams herself down into
the ground
and closes his mouth in the process for
those who read the last chapter you'll
know that mount lady had been holding
his mouth open
but at this point he's now overpowered
her grip and we see an awesome panel in
which he looks back
at mount lady just in disgust like he
just yeah he's disgusted by it
he then proceeds to grab her entire head
with just one of his hands
and throw her away like she's just
nothing just literally flings her out
the way
as he begins to get up we see his giant
hand coming towards mina
which will crush her if it makes contact
just as that's about to happen though
we get this awesome spread of kirishima
going plus ultra
and jumping in front of makiya's palm
and pushing mina out the way
and with that my friends kiroshima is
he's dead
i'm just joking he's not dead he was in
the uh he's in his hardened form so he's
going to be fine
and then tetsu tetsu catches mina and
notes how
despite him and kiroshima both running
side by side
red riot was able to get tamina slightly
faster i mean we all know it's because
kirishima doesn't want his future
wifey to be killed but um i mean in
tests who's mind maybe it's because of
his manliness and his willpower or
something like that according to the
leagues machia then stands up
and has the league of villains in his
palm but the scene then switches to
kiroshima in his unbreakable form
and basically from this panel it looks
like he's scaling gigantomachia's arm
like he's a professional climber or
something he uses his extra sharp
fingers to dig
into making his flesh and just keep
climbing keep climbing until he reaches
his
shoulders and then yeah the two come
face to face the leaks say that as
hiroshima is scaling machia's arm
he says to himself how he will put all
of his regrets behind him
which of course refers to the time where
he didn't act to save
mina and all those other girls from
gigantomachia in the past
this whole chapter so far it's been very
poetic
from the wording we can also probably
assume that kiroshima does recognize
gigantomachia
in the same way that mina did however
there is no confirmation and
it doesn't have to be the case either
because at the end of the day he's still
stepping in to save people
in the way that he didn't before now the
two are face to face
making refers to hiroshima as a little
strawberry which i guess because he's
tiny in red
and kiroshima throws a jar of the
sedative towards machia
but just as he does that togo throws a
perfectly precise knife that cuts
straight through the bottle
before it even really goes anywhere
luckily though all is not lost
because red riot had a second jar on him
but because of what just happened with
toga he begins to doubt himself a little
bit
because i mean when you see the panel
you'll see she basically destroyed the
jar
like as soon as it left his hand for
some reason though the second time
around kiroshima is just too fast
none of the villains can really
intervene and we get this awesome panel
of
kirishima throwing the anaesthetic and
it goes straight into gigantomachia's
mouth
i for one cannot believe one of the
students actually managed to do this
but now it's gonna me wondering will the
sedative will it even work
i'm just thinking like if makia really
gets put to sleep right now
then hirokoshi has really subverted my
expectations
kiroshima is then taken to safety by
setsuna from class 1b
whilst machia starts to complain about
the situation before the chapter ends we
flash on over to the battleground where
shiguraki is currently fighting the pro
heroes
and last time we saw them endeavour had
delivered his vanishing fist attack
right into shiguraki's abs we see
shigeraki on the ground
with smoke just emanating from his body
because obviously endeavors attack would
have been
a firebase attack so yeah shigaraki is
really hot right now
he's smoking he looks weak and in this
situation like
he looks very very vulnerable this is of
course
largely down to professor izawa's
erasure quirk because
because of that shigeraki can't
regenerate in this moment so yeah he's
pretty beat up
the villain then mocks the heroes and
tells them that his father once told him
that heroes save other people rather
than taking care of their own families
this is of course true because when we
look back to marvel and academia
shiguraki's dad's exact words were
heroes of people who hurt their own
families
to help complete strangers this
revelation catches endeavor by surprise
and i personally think it's because he
is the hero perhaps
most representative of what shigaraki's
dad says like
endeavour did nothing but causes family
pain in his quest to become the number
one hero
so i say it probably surprises him
because it's a true statement of fact
about him the leaks say that shiguraki
continues to mumble
incoherently and he mentions something
about a belief that he once had
and i'm assuming that he's referring to
his belief about wanting to be a hero
and forming a hero team with his sister
uh maybe that's it
but we'll find out when the official
thing comes out the chapter ends
with the symbol of evil struggling to
get up but still determined to fight
i gotta say i'm really impressed with
endeavor right now because
sugar rocky's level of strength it's
been stated on a couple of occasions
to be close to all my level i mean
endeavour said it himself gran torino
i'm pretty sure he said it
and of course the doctor said it as well
so to render him
so beat up in this moment uh it's not
it's not an easy task so yeah props to
the number one hero on that
and that was the chapter for this week
guys it was very uh short and sweet i
think
uh heavily focused on mina and kiroshima
and atoning for what happened in the
past i guess
you know when they weren't as brave as
they are now like i said be sure to take
these leaks with a grain of salt
because whilst it's mostly accurate the
dialogue can completely change i mean we
don't even know
so yeah check the official chapter when
it comes out
part two of my walk review will be
coming out this month
though it's impossible for me to do it
this week or next week but after that it
will be my top priority for those of you
who are waiting for that
and uh yeah be sure to check out the
video that i did with my girlfriend
where she was guessing different
characters from my hero academia
she doesn't watch any anime at all so it
was kind of funny
and uh yeah be sure to have a good rest
of your week peace out